Speaker 1: I hope that people understand the
multiple layers of this clip that I'm going
to play for you.
Some of you, I know follow UFC Ultimate Fighting
Championship, which is an MMA League, a mixed
martial arts league or tournament, but I don't
know if they call themselves a league or,
you know, event organizing organization.
One of those fighters, a guy named Bryce Mitchell,
delivered a completely delusional right wing
rant the other day, and we're going to look
at the rant because the rant itself is totally
wacky.
But the other thing that I want to mention
is Donald Trump Jr. retweeted it and said,
I'm with him now.
I just want to remind you guys of the absurdity
of all of these right wingers who say athletes
should just be athletes, shut up and dribble
this type of thing when they don't like LeBron
James is activism, or they don't like Colin
Kaepernick or an Olympic athlete or whatever
making a political point that they don't like.
They say these, you got to keep this stuff.
These are just athletes.
At the end of the day, they should just be
doing their sport.
But when you see a guy like Bryce Mitchell
deliver a delusional right wing rant, Don
Junior all of a sudden loves it.
Now there are so many prototypical fallacies
and red herrings here that it's it's like
a masterclass in lack of critical thinking.
So let's just start and then we'll analyze
as we go.
Speaker 3: Well, I just wanted to get your
thoughts on the whole Russia and Ukraine situation.
You know, here's my first thought is I'm not
going nowhere to fight.
None of these wars for these politicians,
I'm staying at home.
And when the war comes to Arkansas, I will
take my boots on the ground and I will die
for everything I love.
Speaker 1: OK, now that's totally fine.
I'm actually fine with that.
And but now remember, Joe Biden has said he's
not sending troops to Ukraine anyway.
Also, the idea that people are going to invade
Arkansas, I mean, I'm not making fun of Arkansas,
but Arkansas.
If he's like, Well, I'm from Arkansas, I'm
just here to defend Arkansas.
It's unlikely just statistically when you
consider what are the economic centers, et
cetera, that Arkansas is going to be the front
line.
But that doesn't matter so far.
Fine, he's not going to get involved.
He doesn't want to fight the war.
I'm with you.
Speaker 3: I will not retreat if this country
is invaded and everybody's saying, Well, we
got to, we got to evacuate, we got to leave,
we got.
I will not.
I will dig my boots into Arkansas soil and
I will fight for the people that I love.
For the land that I love and a way of life
that I love, but I'm not going overseas to
fight and I don't know what's going on.
To be honest, brother, OK, so
Speaker 1: he admits he doesn't know what's
going on.
Good, that's good.
Speaker 3: There's so much stuff, and I don't
think nobody knows what's going on.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK, so now is where we start
to get to this trope.
I don't think anyone knows what's going on.
It's so complicated.
Nobody can know what's going on, and this
is a typical thing that you hear from.
I mean, listen, we've seen these vaccines,
I mean, syringes, Amrani polyethylene glycol
the virus.
It's sequenced by the AP from a lab or not.
I don't think anyone really understands that.
Well, no, no, no.
You might not understand it, but people do
understand.
So look, there's this invisible air that we
breathe, but it's got oxygen in it, nitrogen
CO2.
I don't think anyone really understands which
of these elements do we really need to survive?
No, actually, we we do know that we actually
you might not know it.
So this is where it starts to get a little
bit fallacious.
And then.
So remember, he said he doesn't know what's
going on and nobody knows what's going on.
Let's continue.
Speaker 3: Wolf, there's been so much political
corruption in that area.
You got Biden and his son making a ton of
money.
Speaker 1: Well, wait.
Hold on a second.
Wait a second.
If you don't know what's going on and you
just aren't sure of what's happening, then
why are you repeating right wing conspiracies
about Joe Biden personally making money from
from?
So it sounds like now you're asserting you
do know what's going on
Speaker 3: off of and using our tax dollars
to bribe their people.
That's treasonous, in my opinion.
Speaker 1: So he goes from, I don't know what's
going on, and I don't want to get involved,
too.
Biden committed treason by using U.S. tax
dollars to bribe someone.
Wait, a second, I thought you said you didn't
know what was going on, Bryce.
Speaker 3: So you got Hunter Biden and his
son using our tax dollars.
Hey, if
Speaker 1: if either way, Hunter Biden's son,
I'm guessing he means Joe Biden, he doesn't
even know the talking points.
Hunter, I didn't even.
This is the son Hunter.
Biden even have a son.
I guess he does.
I don't.
I mean, he's such a non-factor.
I don't even know whether Hunter Biden has
kids, but I've certainly never heard that
they're involved in the conspiracy Iranian
government.
Speaker 3: If you don't do this, we're taking
your tax dollars.
He shouldn't be giving our tax dollars to
that country anyway.
Speaker 1: We know what's really funny is
if you want to buy the way for a guy who doesn't
know anything.
Sure, surely expressing a lot of opinions
if what's funny about this is.
If you don't think things should be held over
the head of Ukraine.
Trump wanted to withhold military aid until
such time that Ukraine got him dirt on Biden
and thanks to Colonel Vindman and others.
Trump ultimately had to release the military
aid to Ukraine.
This guy's criticism, which he claims, I don't
know anything, and now he's making it up.
It actually applies to Trump.
Think about how backwards everything is here
Speaker 3: at veterans out here sleeping on
a street, and you're going to give our frickin
tax dollars to these Ukrainians and our brother.
I don't know what's going on over there, but
I'm not going over there fighting.
And God bless anybody.
It's over.
There's fighting, and I hope that this just
gets solved and I don't like war.
He's against, you know what I mean?
I don't want people dying and all that stuff.
I don't want to be, but I don't know what's
going on there.
So much stuff that I think it's corrupted
that we just don't know what.
Speaker 1: For a guy who says, I don't know
and we don't know.
He sure has a whole hell of a lot of opinions.
And of course, he was spreading all sorts
of misinformation here, and then he was called
out for it.
And then he was his reaction to to that.
Speaker 3: You were recently on the enemy.
Our what was the reception to that interview?
Speaker 1: Like, Oh, I'm sorry.
This is him reacting to.
From what he said on the MMA Hour.
OK?
Speaker 3: Oh, Ariel Helwani.
Yeah.
Well, he kind of he didn't completely seem
to me, but I was spread misinformation and
I don't know, you know, I thought I said a
lot of true stuff and but it's open to a debate.
And you know, I love the Second Amendment
and I love the first and you know why we have
the first, because we have a second.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And so that's a classic classic gun gun gun
person claim.
When someone writes an article saying you
spread misinformation about what you said
on a podcast, the First Amendment just isn't
a factor.
It just has nothing to do with government
censorship of speech.
And so, you know, my view is I don't have
any particular.
Some people say athletes should talk about
politics, and others say they shouldn't the
equivalent of shut up and dribble.
I think anyone should say what's on their
mind in whatever venue they deem appropriate,
and if people don't like it, they can respond
to that and say, I'm not going to patronize
this or that, or I'm not going to pay for
tickets to see whatever.
But whatever you say is subject to review
and to criticism.
And I've heard interesting things said by
athletes before.
What this guy is saying is just utter and
complete nonsense, and he's welcome on the
program any time to discuss any of these topics.
We'll have the clip on Instagram at David
Pakman show.
If you're just listening today, it is worth
watching it rather than just listening.